man what's going on what are you doing
here I'm [__] garage sing showing
people how it's done that's insane yeah
man dude I'm [__] literally filming
I'm in a inflection point in my life
actually how old are you I'm 21 nice I
was finishing up school I'm trying to
move to Colorado my buddy and do some
really creative stuff good for you bro
yeah so we've got like we've been
scripting up some videos and thinking
about starting a podcast and you know
I'm in finance School CU that's what
everybody does around here but I get it
that's like you know [__] that I'm going
to do my own thing go do that you can
always go to finance you can this is
like this is like an I think it is I
really do believe that [__] you could
always go back to that [__] you could do
that at 24 you know what I mean you can
go right back to school 24 I believe in
that [__] yeah go do that go to Colorado